cannes c'est beaucoup d'espoir mais
aussi fatalement pas mal de déception
vous la sentez bien évident cela pas
l'inquiétude ça se dirigent quelque part
espérons de manière générale il y a un
côté très arbitraire dans les
récompenses
malgré toutes les tentatives
d'objectivité du monde elle reste très
marqué par les goûts de ceux qui le
décerne mais aussi par l'air du temps
prenons l'exemple de quentin tarantino
oui vous l'avez compris j'aime prendre
tarantino comme exemple en 2004 il était
président du jury cannois
le contexte international était alors
assez tendue et pour dissiper les doutes
quant à la possible influence de ce
contexte sur la palme d'or tarantino a
tout de suite déclaré qu'elles seraient
attribués sur des critères avant tout
cinématographique pas de récupérations
politiques mesdames et messieurs or qui
a eu la palme cette année la michael
moore avec le brûlot anti bush qui était
fahrenheit nine eleven et oui on a beau
essayer de toutes nos forces d'échapper
à l'air du temps parfois il nous
rattrape avec fracas mais de là à dire
que la palme est uniquement attribué
selon les circonstances du moment
bien sûr que non comme il est souvent
ultra cornélien de départager plusieurs
oeuvres qui sont à la base tout aussi
méritantes les unes que les autres
il y aura toujours une part d'injustice
même involontaire et fatalement certains
films tout indiquée pour figurer au
palmarès passe à la trappe
les exemples ne manquent pas ainsi
pourquoi ne pas récompenser au hasard ou
en fait non pas du tout au hasard
l'homme qui en savait trop hiroshima mon
amour jeremiah johnson midnight express
série noire denman ed wood kids day of
the doc ville de brandon i no country
for old men ou encore enter the void des
films tous devenus cultes à divers
degrés tous sélectionnés mais tous nos b
bien comme il faut
humanité tu te joue deux mois face à ces
cas de figure une question se pose
forcément
est ce que le destin cannois de ses
films aurait été différent s'il avait
été sélectionné une autre année c'est
tout à fait possible
shem de vire au fil des palmarès et des
choix parfois controversés des jurys un
certain nombre de sélectionnés ont donc
pu avoir au fil du temps une impression
de rendez vous manqué avec le festival
car si les récompense cannoise ne font
pas tout ça les empêche pas d'être
sévèrement convoité puisque comme on l'a
vu dans le précédent volet de cette
chronique
elles peuvent offrir un tremplin
d'importance au film en plus des billets
une maison avec un goût certain car tout
bon cinéaste qui se respecte possède une
cheminée a décoré la compétition
cannoise où l'art délicat d'être au bon
endroit au bon moment
en même temps le festival est un
microcosme particulier avec ses
scandales ses coups de gueule ses
controverses ces provocations lars von
triera sq et j'en passe la controverse
fait partie du jeu j'irais même jusqu'à
dire qu'elle est nécessaire au jeu car
sans décision discutable à décrier je
crois qu'une bonne partie du public du
festival se sentiraient orphelines et
donc peut-on trouver dans l'édition 2014
des sélectionnés qui ont une revanche à
prendre sur cannes
bon d'un côté on allait déjà palmés qui
n'ont pas se plaindre comme mike leigh
les frères dardenne ou ken loach mais de
l'autre on a les compétiteurs remontés
comme des coucous comme par exemple
david cronenberg dont le fils thomas
holbein s'est passé presque inaperçu en
2005 xavier dolan qui n'a été jusque là
sélectionné que dans la quinzaine des
réalisateurs est un certain regard et
qui accède enfin à la compétition
officielle
jean luc godard qui en est à sa 7e
sélection mais sans aucune palme d'or à
l'horizon michel hazanavicius dans le
pourtant très récompensé vie artiste n'a
obtenu que le prix d'interprétation
masculine en 2011 bertrand bonello qui
présente cette année saint laurent et
qui s'était fait snober en compétition
officielle avec tiresia en 2003 tommy
lee jones dont la première réalisation
trois enterrements avait raflé les prix
du meilleur scénario et de la meilleure
interprétation masculine en 2005 mais
qui ambitionne probablement de passer la
vitesse supérieure
on pourrait aussi se dire que nicole
kidman veut venger dogville de lars von
trier qui n'avait rien obtenu en 2003
mais vu que grèce de monaco d'olivier
dahan est présenté hors compétition ça
va être un peu difficile
bon tout ça c'est bien joli vous me
direz mais la plupart des films
mentionnés n'ont rien de
particulièrement culte donc recentrons
un peu est ce que certains des
sélectionnés de cette année ont déjà été
par le passé snobé sur une oeuvre
réellement devenue mythique par la suite
et bien non pas vraiment ce que je ne
vous le cache pas m'emmerde un peu vu le
sujet de cette vidéo mais quelque part
ça fait sens déjà parce que les films
qui correspondent réellement à la
définition du culte ils sont rares mais
en plus parmi eux aucun ne se ressemble
et une partie non négligeable entretient
une relation un peu complexes voire même
conflictuelles avec le grand public
prenons par exemple dans la liste des
films cultes oublié du palmarès cannois
que j'ai mentionné un peu avant le cadre
d'un retard de void de gaspar noé noël
c'est un réalisateur qui a toujours
évolué en marche du système et
développer une oeuvre sans concession
qui est quasi religieusement soutenu par
un public issu des contre cultures les
plus intransigeantes être snobé par les
instances officielles à renforcer son
aura de cinéastes alternative sur lequel
il faut compter
en donnant à la plupart de ses films un
goût de chefs-d'oeuvre incompris et on
peut étendre le même constat à d'autres
films comme
l'an denier de vincent gallo la
récompense cannoise peuvent être
bénéfiques mais aussi parfois lourde à
porter pour un film potentiellement
culte après bien entendu je ne dis pas
qu'il faut cloisonné le grand public et
d'un orgue rendent ce serait très
réducteur mais les films cultes dessine
une réalité nuancé sur laquelle il vaut
mieux éviter de généraliser ce qui
empêche de dresser des pronostics trop
précis c'est donc libéré de tout préjugé
que nous pouvons laisser vagabonder
notre imagination et nos espoirs sur le
palmarès 2014 hollanders et ne vous
inquiétez pas à chef d'oeuvre culte dans
le destin a croisé ou croisera cannes
quel que soit votre rapport aux
récompenses vous vous êtes de toute
manière octroyé la plus belle celle de
l'amour inconditionnel de votre public
et donc l'immortalité cinématographique
car oui il ya aussi de beaux sentiments
dans cette émission